[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
fun
I get silly when I'm around you okay one
last one
[Music]
okay here we are and the singing
microphone is here if you need to grab
it um so anyways ladies and gentlemen
welcome back to the podcast the riffin
with Griffin and one of my favorite
people in the whole wide world couldn't
make it so no real brick wall couldn't
make it either here we go comedians to
your place no I gotta check something
real quick we're gonna keep this going
to see keep talking what are you
checking you know you're the only guy
whose podcast I've done who doesn't wear
socks or shoes during the little first
of all the nonsense did Joe Rogan does
on his podcast like I wouldn't be
surprised if he if he was just pantsless
[ __ ] - everybody's just like okay I
guess that's it
okay so you're gonna smoke weed okay I
guess I have to smoke weed - you know
that's I was on his podcast but I'm glad
you here man
welcome again I didn't say his name
welcome mr. Tony hitch cliff Thank You
cliff its hinge clip-in okay on it I
know the trick is all black people do
that by the way I'm not kidding really
it's not a racial it's a racial I
noticed this it's a racial subject but
it's not racist but there's something
about black people they're always like
yo what up [ __ ] cliff yeah even even
this weekend I was doing gigs at the
Pittsburgh improv and they you know and
their green room they do this always
happen I mean you know they always write
on the chalkboard
welcome to the improv you know Tony
hinge goes right in the green room and
it was a it said welcome Tony hitch
cliff HIPC H and I'm like I'll bet you
anything I got a black waitress it's a
and underneath that it said tonight your
waitress is a like Malaysia or something
like that um oh yeah and it
now when that happens and you have a
sort of like stereotype thought mm-hmm
do you feel like well I knew it or is it
like it doesn't even bother me it's it's
cooler to even notice it and I only
noticed that because I hang out with so
many black people and I'm always around
them you know what I mean it's always
like you know for a guy that doesn't
hang out with black people they wouldn't
even notice that there wouldn't be like
black people it's just a weird name
though ya know it you know it's like it
sucks especially for like in the social
media error yeah I mean people were just
like they can't find you no you're right
in fact a fun fact about my podcast kill
tony is that the first episode it wasn't
even called kill Tony it was called
hinge CliffsNotes like a play on like
CliffsNotes kill Tony
so that's dope had to simplify it yeah I
know are you a bunch of people in the
hood we're looking up hitch CliffsNotes
[Laughter]
some [ __ ] gonna get it right now and
it's just all my jokes that work with
black people it's like Sarah Tiana I
always call her T on E
yes Tiana whatever yeah she says it to
be all the time eonni yeah it looks like
that so you [ __ ] say it like well
everyone every black person has a cousin
named T on E
yeah it just sounds like that's what it
should be you know I mean I don't know
yeah but look I'm in the game you know I
went on you actually you were the first
podcast that I went on that I announced
I was having a podcast you know and and
you started with the kilt oh no no I
always a Tony bump yes that first 35
people that this is a tough thing you
know you've been doing it for how many
years now over six years you don't have
to wait you don't want what you don't
know what are these it's okay no I'm
fine okay you're comfortable something
just blew on me from like the ceiling oh
that's just the air conditioning and
your hair so much yeah
my hair fall yeah yeah so I did it and
so here I am and it's just like I would
have wrote look I'm doing this all by
myself you know I gotta go put the
camera I gotta check the camera during
the podcast my phone is going on wet and
bullets no sweat I have the a/c on maybe
I'm nervous center one of the hottest
rising young comics in the business
right one of them one of the top young
rising stars is he a little mechanics
towel I know I feel like G thing you
know that's a sweaty [ __ ] right
there you know but I never yeah I don't
know why I'm so hot right now
um I know now I have one of the hot
rising young podcasts in the game yeah I
don't know podcasting is just such a
weird thing but you know what I really
want to talk to you about is how do you
let's say your friend right has a
superhot wife okay and her Instagram
profile is just fire you know pictures
such as like and I'll probably put them
up here you know obviously I'm making
reference to like cuz you're married
good for you you had a whirlwind romance
and got married but your wife is just
like beautiful you know she's such a
sweetheart - yeah but I forget that this
person that I see at the convent when
she comes and she's like you know just
normal just a little too bubbly nice
they're probably nice girl with
Australian accent and then I catch
myself being a creep on Twitter not to
Instagram and I'm like oh damn oh [ __ ]
that's Tony's wife yeah so like what
would you do you know I look I look I
uncle instead of friends hot wife's
Instagram but I can't like yeah what do
you do I'm just saying cuz you're me
this is this is new because like you're
now a young millennial married in this
social media era and this is how it is
how is that being married when everybody
has so much access to information about
you
no really it's just like the one of this
one of the silly things that I don't
really like I don't really care about it
well you know what I mean
I just which is why it works there
rarely is it even a is it even a thing
that's good like it's like on you know
there's been a couple jokes made about
it on TV like on like roast battle and
stuff like you know tony has a model
wife or whatever you know so like trolls
here and they're like are you guys new
and really married like where's your
wife I don't post pictures like with her
like my troll sound like that yeah all
my page is just you know promoting [ __ ]
I never see you on her profile right
right we both use our profiles yeah
strictly for work and so yeah you know
what I mean we're not like no you know
we are public like where we like to hang
or chill or anything I don't like myself
I don't want anybody yeah and I've done
that before and I got once posted a
story that I was at one of my favorite
pizza places in Columbus like so glad to
be here at Adriana cos I'm like all
these [ __ ] frat boys came in in Los
Angeles I mean you feel like in it you
don't want to feel like an [ __ ] like
you don't want to feel like like I love
fans I really do and like you know
coming from like workaholics and being
Montez you know it's like I'm talking
about just you know it's like 1 out of
20 so I'm not like super famous or
anything but like the ones that know
workaholics and love it they are on top
of that [ __ ] they just come up to you
anywhere and everywhere like you know
they just know all the lines and yeah
you know it's it's like you have a
moment though where you want to be like
yeah but you gotta go hey it's good to
see you then what's your proud and what
you're gonna end up noticing is that the
podcast fans are there they're a little
bit more chill but they're also a little
bit more like not scary like it's not
the right word but you just ER instead
of how Montez gets like a WoW Montez
like when you do a lot of podcasts and
people listen to you for an hour hour
and a half every single week whatever
sometimes two three times a week then
all of a sudden you get like this stare
from people that's just like it's not
like
it's more like yeah I don't you probably
get this all the time I want to bother
but I'm you know what I mean it's more
like that so sometimes I wish that it
was reversed where I'd have like that
like what but instead I just have people
like staring at me like wanting to say
then they end up usually usually they do
cuz I'm a nice guy yeah I'd like to be
nice to people people think I'm a people
thing you assume that I'm like an
[ __ ] cuz I am on the show you have a
you have a chip on your shoulder it
feels like sometimes it feels like you
have a chip on your shoulder and my
question is is that a real chip or is it
manufactured to push yourself no it's
it's it's the real deal it's always been
there really like where's it come from
what's it about everything man I'm a
bastard you know what I mean rough
childhood tough tough tough neighborhood
I grew up in you know where'd you grow
young Stan Ohio Oh crime capitals of the
country when I was growing up there sure
it still is but when I was growing up
there was like the murder capital of
America
per capita which basically means the
most dangerous neighborhood you could
live in my house was right in the middle
of it all like you know just broken into
house all the time at least once a year
is this a predominantly white area they
lived on the poor white area or was it
just like Jaipur and it was there all
the poor it was the poor black area oh
wow it was a very black neighborhood
which is fun you know it got me good at
football and basketball at a young age
as ridiculous as that sounds we were you
like white chocolate when you were
playing or they they call you like did
you have like a nickname yeah a little
[ __ ] little [ __ ] I'm open hey Glen
oh man so well that's okay so I get it
so you you know so how I started
stand-up like it's like you know I found
something that I loved and I just went
completely all-in didn't have money
didn't save money beforehand you know
slept in my car that whole thing working
my way out the store took the hardest
possible approach wanted to get really
good instead of just really famous you
know what I mean like I wasn't on I
didn't want like
like fast-track like type of like
crapola you know what I mean I took that
real crazy Comedy Store path was an
employee forever learned the ins and
outs I remember those days you're doing
that yeah when we're taking you am at to
that weird gig up north mm-hmm yeah and
yeah I don't think you lose that chip
even like the nice guys that work at the
Comedy Store three four years in you
start to see them like Anakin Skywalker
like they sort of like turn a paler
color their eyes get a little bit icy
blue like the night King from Game of
Thrones they just sort of like freeze
over I know what you're saying yeah man
well I think tonight I personally
believe that the nice guys gotta
consider myself a nice guy you know you
go through you I think you had that chip
especially at the store because if you
don't ask for what you want or fight for
what you want or you know you're gonna
you're gonna get passed over people are
not gonna oh yeah you know that's one I
had to deal with Tommy you know after
being passed by midsi I had to deal with
Tommy and he was just a nightmare to
deal with but like I don't regret those
times because it helped me I really
appreciate that like that struggle you
know he was my enemy but it was
manufactured for me but but it was real
you know how I thought about my gloves
tough cookie man and I'm telling you he
gets a bad rep and you know there's
definitely some things he did that were
that were completely wrong but for the
people that he sort of built up I
wouldn't change a thing I don't I don't
necessarily want a talent coordinator
that [ __ ] adores me you know what I
mean so just like make it a little who
wants that head coach you know what I
mean it's certainly not what [ __ ]
Belichick is like before going to every
goddamn Super Bowl it's [ __ ] tough
love he wants you to get better at
absolutely everything he wants to be
able to throw catch run ladder roll
[ __ ] running back take a toss so you
have to be able to do everything just
want to be a New England Patriot not
doing it right you want him to be like
your mama should have never had you with
that jokes right you know you wanted to
be pushed like one of the things for
example and I was just talking about
this the other day cuz someone was
telling me oh yeah someone was telling
me one of the door guys was telling me
the other night that he had this dream
that uh
[Music]
that they were putting names on the wall
right it was the same day that they put
names on the wall so he saw an Instagram
by the comic store he goes to sleep that
night next day he's telling me it's like
I had this dream last night that uh that
Adam who's the talent coordinator now of
course real listeners that Adam asked me
is there anything from your past that I
need to know about you and he's like no
nothing no nothing and he's like all
right well you're not you're not you're
still not past and like this dream like
messed with him and he's telling me
about this and he goes I think I need to
I think it's I think I need to get out
of LA man I think I need to go to New
York or something I'm like that's so
funny because that is not how I would
interpret that dream at all yeah if I
had that dream where the talent
coordinators saying is there anything
from your past I need to know about you
I would be dwelling on that for at least
two hours to start my day of what is
something from my past that I don't have
a joke about that I need to make a joke
about then Adam will see you know what I
mean the talent coordinator will see to
me that's him that's his you know
whatever the unconscious mind saying
there's a joke that you haven't made
from your past that's on the surface let
me give you another example full circle
because Tommy who was the talent
coordinator that broke us that I'm
talking about when I was still an
employee there and I lived with other
employees and whatnot we all had this
apartment that was with like five door
guys me Matador sandy danto Toma Dona
raisi and I was in a living room date a
lot of those guys had their own bedroom
and you'd have to walk through the
bedroom to use the bathroom it was a
debacle again that's early on in my
story this is 12 years ago see we talked
about a chip on his shoulder it's like
if you think I'm letting any of this a
little bit of success that I have go you
got to be a crazy so when I walk you're
right when I walk into this store that's
what you're feeling is the guy that
slept on a couch in his car on a beanbag
on a futon
an air mattress one time I slept on an
air mattress that had a hole in it I on
the floor I was yes you stepped on a
layer of plaster and the sad thing is
people don't realize this is that if you
have a hole in your ear air mattress you
you can blow it up right with the vacuum
thing that pushes the air out and then
you lay on it and it doesn't like fall
down evenly you fall down in the middle
and the rest closes up like a Venus
flytrap around you so you just symbolic
of your situation but anyway one time
Tommy this is how like you know wild he
was with his like ways he told all my
buddies because he's their talent
coordinator too but he would he would
send messages other ways hoping that it
would get back to you you know what I
mean and Tommy had this theory 100%
convinced that I was gay
no I get you know I've gotten in my
whole life I sounded about a lot of
people right I sound sort of feminine I
look sort of feminine to go get it right
I was raised by a single mom I have two
older sisters I get it right anyway so
he told my buddies that Tony's gay and
he's convinced of it and he's never
gonna pass me until I admit to being gay
and talk about it on stage and do jokes
about it about being gay right and and
the guys all told me within like 48
hours separately like hey Tony I mean I
don't know how to break this see what
Tommy told me something really crazy
said that he thinks you're gay and he's
not gonna pass you until you would you
know talk about being gay he says you
need to acknowledge it to finally break
through to the other side so I'm like oh
[ __ ] you know the first couple days I'm
like [ __ ] this guy right am I supposed
to do I have to [ __ ] a dude and the
[ __ ] get past the comedies because I
will know and and I end up writing a
joke about how I look gay and it ended
and it was it was all just broken down
and - you know what I mean that was my
gay face joke from way back okay my
opener which I just rode that momentum
throughout sets and it was a big joke
for me for a couple few years and when
I wrote that joke and started crushing
with it right from the top acknowledging
what people were seeing and noticing
Tommy passed me so it's sort of like one
of those roundabouts right maybe that's
what he wanted but I don't I just think
that like I think he stumbled into that
madness I don't always think that that
was his intention what was going on but
just like being in that environment and
like probably being around midsi for as
long as he was he sort of picked up on
some things but didn't understand why
they worked and but sometimes he got it
you know what I mean so I I agree I mean
it was like I had a chip on my show and
I for me the chip was like when I said
to myself [ __ ] this place I was like I'm
done with dealing with this [ __ ] you
know like those mondays like you know
like Frasier would be hosting and he
you're next you're next you know and
then all of a sudden uh hey we gotta put
this I told this guy there was one day
did that happen I was like I'm out by I
say just take me off the list and I
[ __ ] left yeah and it was after that
that us that soon after that is when I
like it just started to click where it
was like this doesn't mean anything it's
not as important as I'm making it out to
be
yeah you know and just like but I had
that chip I always noticed that chip on
your shoulder too though it keeps me
hungry that's what keeps me right where
I am
but how do you see me I don't have big
TV credits I'm not in movies I don't
have any of that so that chip is that's
the [ __ ] fire starter right there
that is that what you want though do you
want that do I want what main access yes
do you want mainstream success I mean of
course sure I mean I guess so in a way
it's been a fun ride being sort of
underground filling up venues if that
makes sense yeah selling out big places
people that actually know me and my
style in my show and my stand-up and all
this is it enough
no it's never enough are you kidding me
there's some gonna do arenas I'm gonna
fly a private jet one day I want to fly
my own goddamn jet aircraft and you know
the funny thing about it is like you
were talking about this I had Russell
Peters on the podcast and I kind of felt
like he felt the same way about like
wanting to get that acceptance from
Hollywood and stuff but talk about
selling out arenas and stuff and being
filthy rich you know I mean it's like
it's funny how the grass is always
greener
ABB's
lutely no doubt about it and I'm sure
there's some people out there that are
famous right that wish they had fans
that they didn't that they didn't hate
right there's some people out there that
you know got big breaks or whatever and
probably got weird shows and whatever in
this cent like look at like old TV
sitcom stars right like old school ones
yeah like some living single or
something yeah or even like Kramer right
before he did all of his crazy stuff
like imagine you're going you know
Kramer from Seinfeld and now you're
going to see Michael Richards and it's
not Kramer you know probably he probably
does something like something to get the
crowd going crazy like it probably comes
in all weird I think he was doing
something like that he's got to be I
mean he was like I can't do this yeah
let me sit on my millions in but it's
like imagine the the dummies that go out
and see a sitcom star that they don't
know they're stand-up if that makes
sense so it goes both ways but they
still do it the new the newsstand at
that night now is like you know social
media people you know youtubers and
people like that that people love what
they do it's like you know I come from
this old school and it's so hard to deal
with sometimes you know there was that
guy that had a he just had a trouble at
jfl he's like that long here why do
country something-or-other
he doesn't care country mama is that
like a year ago yes yeah I was at the
Huntsville I was at the Huntsville funny
bone not funny bone um The Stand Up
Stand Up y-yeah Huntsville and link for
some reason they had him doing the Early
Show and I was doing the Late Show you
know and it was just like all these
people you know and they're just like
yell I'm trying to do two bits and he's
just up there doing his thing and he's
doing a meet and greet on the stage just
cutting into my time you know it's
cutting Monta there's people in the
greenroom that I don't even know who the
[ __ ] these people are his cousin and
like you know special needs dude is in
there I'm like what's happening right
now some huntsville alabama he just did
but he just had no i didn't care about
this brotherhood
like to process you know he didn't care
about it it didn't it felt to me like
you know I forgot his name though but
anyway don't matter and you'll never
need to remember it people like that
you'll never so he but he like ran
delight in like you know that the things
going on by my whatever fans are outside
waiting to come in there giving them
drinks outside because they're like this
is you know
oh my you know and then and then they
ask him about it he go hey can you not
do that and he slips out the next day
doesn't even longer you know what I mean
and I'm just thinking to myself dude you
don't know me bro right like you know
it's like what are you doing and then
the owner calls me and he's like Eric
I'm so sorry but in my mind I was like
you booked us dude right like you are
you sorry right you know it's all you
care about is this [ __ ] yeah there's no
love for the game anymore there's no
love for the art or the craft or
cultivate we're not in we're not in
business together anymore it's just you
selling drinks and food and you don't
care about anything else not saying
that's not you know what you're supposed
to do that if some of that has to be
part of it right but damn can we can we
like can we be in unison with certain
things
it was just like but anyway those type
of guys are the new they're just out
there doing it man yeah I've been around
somebody's social media guides and you
know a few years ago and they all were
like oh can you be in one of my sketches
and that guy stuff as if like what I'm
doing like that's gonna add some
legitimacy to them but cut to now they
know that they are the actual stars yeah
yeah like all that [ __ ] is done
they don't care anymore hey they don't
care about getting on TV they don't care
about doing movies they're just like
you're fine with their podcast and
they're twenty five million followers
yeah they're making money off the
YouTube ads good to make it money off
that like shows suck though that's the
catch is that people go see them do
shows live and then they think that's
what a live professional show is like
and that's the part that bothers me is
like some of these Millennials that got
hooked on some janky YouTube show now
think that that is what it's like to see
a live show whereas you go see someone
that's [ __ ] grind it out a real
career and knows how to work everything
if it goes bad or good
or whatever how to do everything do they
even want to sit in there for an hour
that's the thing - yeah it's just an
hour it's like a hour and a half show
like most of the time yeah that's one of
those fool me once things when you go
see a YouTube star live yeah that was
like Last Comic Standing I think was the
same kind of thing yeah you know cuz he
would go to clubs and you were here by
dad he's an onerous I feel like yeah we
did the Last Comic Standing we paid all
these people then the next time around
it was like okay we're not selling any
tickets and stuff like that what's going
on here yeah so it's like a weird like
you know whatever I don't know man I
just because the people who what people
are watching that Last Comic Standing
that's like what quality of person is
watching what channels that one of the
big three yeah when by big three I mean
unwatchable right garbage networks that
you still want to be on really see
that's not really what I want to do it's
like I don't know I'm thinking about
things yeah but I could totally see in a
showrunner on some nope MBC show
possible I could see if the offer came
in today there'd be no chance you
wouldn't do it wouldn't do it there's no
amount of money that you would do it
nope okay freer on his show no way yeah
well yeah absolutely not no even if it
was your vision no no I would never have
a vision on those networks though
okaying is like nothing that goes to
commercials for [ __ ] you know
straight to goddamn Clorox bleach wipes
or whatever like what to you reading an
ad on your pocket I like reading hats on
my podcast I've like I'm super critical
no it's not no it's not because that's
different when I because to me reading
your own ads to me reminds me of one of
my original favorite things ever which
was the original Howard Stern Show on FM
radio and he would read those ads and
they were so it made no sense it felt it
felt can contrary to who he was like you
know Vermont Teddy Bear I got one I got
one for my my daughter my wife my
girlfriend I got one for everybody and
like why is he finally buying teddy
bears and why is he buying a dozen roses
from this rose company like what is this
she was paying bills damn right
so now when I go straight into it I love
it it reminds me of that where as like
yeah but when the NBC show goes to the
Clorox commercial that's the same thing
but on a grander scale now if I was
doing the Clorox commercial myself I'd
be down so you'd want to like smell your
show remember Alfred Hitchcock used to
sort of do his own ads like that I'd be
down for well this would be your show
this how you would do it and you would
say you would say we never go to
commercial break we stay in the show but
within the show we do commercial hey
I've pitched this it goes nowhere it
goes nowhere I pitched the whole show
just commercials it's just a commercial
show every once in a while we take a
break go to a comedy show some sketches
play we'll be right back with more
commercials that's what it feels like
anyway yeah I remember did you ever in
for Last Comic Standing nope
not my thing yeah went once and I
regretted it so much yeah I really
regretted it just because how they were
acting and stuff and I was like what am
I doing here well the whole thing was
rigged you know what am i doing you know
the whole thing was rigged I don't know
if we're allowed to talk about this on
podcast can we now is it right now on
your podcast you might take the heat
heard it here first standing was
you know run by one of the biggest
managers in town at the time and he
would have his own clients when it
wasn't voted on it so that's a bunch of
baloney and even if it was voted on the
way that they show clips and everything
and I'm sure everybody knows this they
decide they they they know what you're
going to pick they know what you're
going to vote on it's even like the
current presidential [ __ ] I know what
they're doing they know they got to keep
Bernie sort of like off to the side like
I mention him last you know they want
their you know they decide media decides
everything media chose Trump well well
they did and and for good reason for
them that their numbers are crazy right
now people can't stop following the
hysteria I know me but all these
buffoons everywhere thinking that the
world is ending well the economy's
booming people love to hate the guy I
mean they see his name all the time you
know it's like it shows like SNL and all
the late-night shows they should send
them a gift basket every day you know
because their ratings are so high he
doesn't like just talking about him all
the time oh they're the only reason they
never mentioned one of the you know 185
candidates yeah that are running for the
demo company every day they find a way
to like you know it's like Trump talk oh
yeah you know whoever that doesn't mean
they're gonna get smashed there's simply
no way he's an old man like Joe Biden
he's just barely holding on looks like
he should be holding like a candlestick
in the middle of the night with
something hat or something yeah oh he's
like Ebenezer yeah yeah I don't know
yeah Bernie's like ghost of Christmas
past
Elizabeth Warren is just a mrs. Claus
the whole thing's beat up takes by Tony
hinge clip my boy Tim Ryan's running
though congressman out of a Youngstown
Ohio oh that's your boy yeah did you
know I yeah very well are you guys
welcome would you go up in the same
shitty neighborhood no he's a little bit
older than me but I used to do a bartend
for him when I right before I moved out
here I worked the lunches at a little
Italian restaurant and
and he just came to kill Tony a few
weeks ago he was in LA bill maher show
and a bunch of cool stuff and he came
sat in a booth that kill Tony it was so
cool him his campaign manager his
brother it was awesome so if anyone's
listening from Iowa or any of the picker
states Tim Ryan he's a centrist Democrat
who's like a Democrat that hunson [ __ ]
he would win if people knew anything
about candidates like he speaks well
he's cool he has unbelievably great
ideas he's all about like changing the
way people eat to help the country like
he's like enough with this [ __ ] yeah
but if you don't it doesn't matter that
kind of stuff doesn't matter you think
that no no but I'm saying like Michelle
Obama was all about being right but
because Michelle Obama yeah that's what
they look like in the back of a magazine
somewhere like oh by the way Michelle
Obama cares about what you eat but if
the president literally was like making
you know charging fast-food places out
of the wazoo
for taxes that should be the syntax
right there I mean I'm telling you
absolutely how do you feel after eating
if you ate a Big Mac at 11 crazy I you
know I write on the same page with this
dude if it's like first of all I always
say like you know if you want health
care if you want the government to pay
for health care I need some restrictions
okay restriction one if you smoke go
[ __ ] yourself
okay you smoke [ __ ] you yeah you don't
care about yourself you don't care about
the people around you why should we pay
for your health care I completely you
should get a high deductible right
number two is like if your body fat is
that a certain percentage [ __ ] you too
yeah you know that's not all we say I
just I have jokes about this it's not
Ebola you know you didn't get on a bus
and effect girl sneeze and all of a
sudden you were like oh no you were
eating like a [ __ ] [ __ ] your whole
life yeah and this is why you're fat
yeah and so now you wanna you want to
get all the benefits of health care no
you have to have a high deductible right
going to the gym should be free yeah
that should be on library yes yeah like
going to going to the gym you should be
able to go and that should because this
call it's preventative medicine yeah
like
preventive medicine should be part of
the health care system and then okay
then we could talk about paying for but
people just want like I want to do
whatever I want
let me give you a great example I always
pick up the tab every time me and the
crew are out on the road as usual eating
breakfast lunch or dinner right and the
only time that I ever eat McDonald's is
if it's very early in the morning like
I'm talking like it's got to be between
I'm about to get always only at the
airport I have to be getting ready to
get on a plane between 5:00 a.m. and
7:00 a.m. I won't eat it after 7:00 a.m.
I have to know I'm going right to sleep
because I sleep like a baby on airplanes
and I've learned that I have to eat
something
oh now the only thing that I'll ever eat
from McDonald's for the rest of my life
is for some reason and they're
disgusting I don't know why I do it
still gross Egg McMuffin no it's the
little breakfast burritos a little
fajita burrito thanks for summary I know
it's so weird they have this gross
fajita sauce and by gross I mean a maze
like there's so wrong it's so wrong and
I always get all gassy and disgusting
after you go to the bathroom before
getting on the anyway so I'm like hey
guys it'll go to another
now Micro that I work with they're all
just Pig monsters they anything I mean
Jeremiah and red ban and Joel are human
garbage disposals without it I don't
know how Jeremiah does it like where
does he put it it's just all in his nose
Jeremiah is one of the freakiest eaters
of all time well we'll eat a lot alike
so are you guys like it's thinking about
like going to dinner or something like
that like literally you know okay are
you you're not kidding I mean if you're
hungry we might have to you know if
we're probably not gonna eat again
tonight so we might as well eat a lot
now I'm like we just ate
you just had anyway so I get McDonald's
and I get it for you know the crew and
the totals like 18 dollars right
literally and I'm like what is wrong
with our society yeah - we're only when
you're eating the shittiest [ __ ] is it
that affordable like it's like oh you
get to feel like [ __ ] for the rest of
the day aren't we the only country where
the poor people are fast
right it's crazy that's that's the whole
point is it's like are the the food
stuff and they didn't teach me this in
Ohio I always thought California was
like weird and hippie and like oh
there's no right exactly and then you
get here and you're like no I felt good
after drinking that beet juice yeah oh
that ginger shot really made you know
made me feel good I just recently
started changing my [ __ ] up and you know
I mean she man and you know and another
thing was Rogan really helped me with
that is it's like food isn't food isn't
just meant to be this like mouth helper
thing it's not like supposed to be like
this great sensation all the time yes it
should taste good
but you should find you know we should
be able to find stuff that we like that
tastes good that gives us energy it's
about energy it's not about some reward
like it's like a you know yeah that's
exactly how we make you feel like well I
mean I went I went to this place called
next health you know because cuz I I was
I was getting a little nervous just
because of like what's going on my mom
my mom you know it's dealing with
dementia and it's hard it's a lot and
then you read about it and you find out
it's like when you have high cholesterol
when you have high blood pressure low
testosterone and and all these kind of
things you look at it you go oh man
maybe you can't totally prevent this
from happening but maybe you could
obviously you know you could be a lot
healthier so I that's what I did I went
I got a blood test and I found out [ __ ]
my vitamin D level was super low yeah
you know and I was like oh man you don't
people don't even know these things this
is like preventive medicine so like now
I'm starting to take these supplements
I'm taking vitamin D and man more energy
my hair is luscious up here it was like
you know all these kinds of things and
then now I got a Food Program coming you
know instead of like you know ordering
GrubHub every day you know like it's a
single guy you know if you know spending
$40 on a meal and eating all of it right
now I'm getting these little portion
meals and I just I feel better and I'm
starting and I'm trying to I'm slimming
down a little bit the whole point is
feeling better yes
I mean and it's like even slimming down
and losing weight like yeah that'll
happen that'll come but really it's
about mental health I think that there
is a huge connection between eating
shitty and feeling shitty yeah and I
remember when I was in Ohio I didn't
know any difference so you're just going
to Chipotle every day and you know a and
I like actually I love Chipotle that's
what you say you know one of the things
on the rotation like you know pizza for
example like it's like only now if I I
could by the way you know we live this
crazy comedian life and I like to have
fun at night I smoked a lot of pot I
have a few drinks I only feel hungover
now I could go last night I went crazy
at the Comedy Store woke up today 9:00
a.m. running right ready but I eat food
before bed and [ __ ] these over a whole
next day is [ __ ] and it's like no one
teaches you that in Ohio hungry that's
what people say it's like that no go to
bed hungry what yeah or don't just eat
when you're full you'll eat to your full
you know but about my problem is if it's
in front of me I'll eat it right so then
I have to have portion control yeah
that's the thing so that's why I realize
I shouldn't control control is that that
song from Prince no [ __ ] control no I I
do agree with you that imagine how much
the country would change you have people
would be able to work harder work more
better life better family mental health
all of these things if the entire
country was aware instead you have
McDonald's logos everywhere
Burger King sponsoring the college
football then they want to catch
themselves like you know putting a salad
on the menu right the Tostitos Fiesta
Bowl why why is that the Fiesta Bowl
these things should all have to pay
government tax if you're not healthy you
pay heavy taxes if you're not on the
contrary end if you're making healthy
stuff you should get
brakes you like a Tesla yep you know you
know you know I mean like if I even for
us like when you go to the supermarket
you know like if you buy a Tesla you get
a tax break right so like if you if you
buy all healthy food it should be like
okay so this is lower taxed food you
know so you could your but then but the
problem is that's the most expensive
food I mean the problem really is to eat
healthy it is expensive to take care of
yourself as expensive look I'm going to
this place it's called next health is
pricey
yeah it's a certain amount of money a
month so like I go do cryo and I'm you
know I give massages and I think it
because it's good for I didn't realize
what it did for blood pressure I mean I
realize if I didn't like have the amines
to do some of these things I just if I
just lived a regular life man I probably
have diabetes right now and and high
blood pressure high cholesterol and all
these kinds of things and you know just
because but I'll I've been blessed with
a you know a decent life so that's just
suck that's the push bag is that we
don't make it easy to be healthy you
know understand that's one of my point
is that's one of the big things that Tim
Ryan who's just buried behind like 13
candidates the day this guy can barely
get his mic turned on in the debates and
everything but he smashes everyone he
gets a chance I would I appreciate what
you're doing right now saying you know
this is it I don't know all the
candidates I don't know who I'm gonna
vote for who I want to vote for but to
learn about one guy that's great
yeah so if you're out here right now
you're and you're not sure who you want
to vote for if you're independent you
know or even if you're a Democrat but
you're not really involved and all you
want to do is hate on the president
here's an exchange to be like you know
what let me find out about this guy
right let me go look into this guy and
then take that opportunity to start
looking into some other people so we can
really make a difference that's how
we're really gonna make a change right
Ana centrist Democrat means that he's
towards the middle in this far end I
mean I don't want to get too deep into
politics but let's just say like stuff's
a little wacky over on the far left
right now
I think it's well that there are these
diesels far dairy they're the same you
could just flip them they're like a
circle and it turns around and it feels
like they're the exact same people don't
like though yeah it felt like the right
was
crazier back in the George W Bush days
right like it was sort of like oh
they're extreme and like Fox News was
extreme right but now it's sort of like
well what we're realizing that they're
all the same right I always say Rachel
Maddow and like yep Sean Hannity yep
they're the same right they even have
the same haircut yep I mean yeah they're
exactly the same
yeah so it's like you you know you just
that you make just say I always loved
watching like they both get the same
amount of [ __ ] - I don't know I just I
just feel like you know we have to like
find a way to like get that message out
for people to take care of themselves
but you know it's just it's hard you
know people don't want to yeah easy for
some others like I'm older now so it's
like I it is hard but here's the thing
when I went and got that blood test and
so the guys talking to me I love them
too because it was a super gay guy and
he was like you know really in a you
know healthy and he was just like we
gotta get these numbers down you know I
mean it was just like he was so invested
in and I was like what do I got to do
tell me what I gotta do you know and so
like he was telling me about my insulin
levels and why I had he was like I bet
you have cravings and and I was like I
do have these cravings so once I started
to like cut out certain things but and
then you know fit I don't I used to
drive won't be like I gotta get a
doughnut what I was just gonna say like
Jeremiah don't shop at you know
yeah Jeremiah a couple days ago had an
apple fritter like it's like a sandwich
and I'm just sitting there I'm driving
us he's just sitting shotgun doing
nothing just be eating food
an apple fritter like you couldn't hold
is Jeremiah is he still in his 20s or is
he like I think he's in his early third
house anyway it's about to change
yeah he's gonna wake up one day be like
what you know we put on 30 pounds in one
month are so [ __ ] insane with your
[ __ ] man
this is that podcast Brotherhood of
nonsense I just I'm just not in that
I'm actually not in the crew you know
I'm really like a common that's not true
well I'm not in the crew I figure you
were in there you're in there with them
I'm in the outskirts I'm I'm in like if
it was an onion I'm not in the inner
layer I'm not you know Segura you know
it even Andrew Santino's in there now
you know Andrew and you know these
people they're right there you know
Rogen's in the center he's the center of
the podcast universe for this comp the
West Coast comedy theater I mean he's
there and I'm just not there you're good
you're fine what episode is this this
will be like 42 exactly a month or like
370 right what you guys do like do you
have that kind of stuff you guys are
game and wait together come on you're
doing the same thing over here on your
own
all by dammit I walked right into
nothing what is that noise you on the
toilet I got that good boy you grew up
with a black night we're gonna Nationals
whoa
right oh my god I actually had when I
was one of my neighbors we will Jenkins
a real black neighborhood I want to see
the whoo life story he's got his old
life story oh man what are you thinking
- let's talk about this now like what do
you feel about the what do you feel
about the state a comedy you know you
know what's going on do I wait how far
do I want to go today we want to thank
hand hang over candles hang I think I
said it right hand something candles the
guy's great
but anyway he made the candles go ahead
so let me see what I want to say here
today um
you trying to have a measured approach
right now yeah very measured because
there's something interesting happening
right now now it's interesting that you
say those words because I think that's
what's happening in comedy is that we
have to take a measured approach that's
my take on like what we've had to do
like you can't you know you know it's
like these people that say like you know
comedy should be offensive economy
should be this and that I said not
necessarily right you know comedy should
be sought out and yeah and I'm smart it
should be small and it should be
balanced you guys like you you know what
I mean
being a little bit more light silly
mixed with people like me when mixed
with people like Holtzman mixed with you
know what I mean right
every everybody should be doing what
they specialize in but what is
interesting to me right now when it
comes to comedy is we have now fallen
into an interesting time right all the
movies are remakes there's no original
ideas
I saw a billboard on my way here from a
new men in black I don't even know who
the two people are on it I'm like Tessa
Thompson and what's-his-face who's that
who's Tessa wrong she's a lot she's done
a lot of stuff I got a really great
actress that's like the beating they
beat down all these movies anyway let me
skip the movies analogy right let's go
straight to the comedy no I like to move
because I think what's missing in movies
is like with there's no more raunchy
rated our comedies because they're too
afraid right they're too afraid like you
can't hit cuz you cuz
because how can you have a raunchy way
to do our comedy and not have if it's if
there's males in it
yeah if there's good if it's males
there's gotta be titties yeah gotta be
that you're talking about sex you're
talking about gross stuff you talk about
you know so they like oh they're afraid
we can't do that we can't talk about
that you know so it's also this let me
tell you something interesting and this
is the first place I'm talking about
this here we go here we go breaking news
is gonna be a good conversation because
no one else is having this conversation
because every white person in the world
is afraid to bring this up but I'll
bring this up with you I think this is
perfect okay let's do it let's do it
there's a thing happening right now
where the diversity of things has
flipped right it has flipped upside down
now normally historically there's
usually what what do they call it what a
token black eye on a normal show unlike
it not a normal show but a mostly white
show because you know I guess what it
probably used to be mostly white people
in America or whatever I don't know but
now an interesting thing is happening
where the tables have completely flipped
right so let me just give you this
example so I went to see once upon a
time in Hollywood this past week and now
of course once upon a time in
Hollywood's a Tarantino film so there's
Leo DiCaprio Brad Pitt there's white
actors bla bla bla bla of course
Tarantino can get away with it it's his
ninth film he's one of the great
filmmakers of all time he can get away
with it whatever but I'm watching the
trailers before the movie okay now this
is where shit's interesting is the first
movie was the Harriet Tubman movie now
through the trailer there's only one
white guy and guess who he is the bad
guy right the slave master yeah guy I'm
gonna get you lady and you'll never have
another chance again during the Harriet
Tubman time no I get that I get that but
these are the movies that are being made
these are the movies that are being made
right now that are being promoted but
every year though there is it you know
during a Tarantino movie I would see the
yeah you're gonna promote you know hear
me out
so that's the first trailer okay
the next trailer is Charlie's Angels so
you got four women
the trailer is unwatchable yeah it's a
garbage pile now
let's so we got all women on that one
though a white guy that they show is the
villain mm-hmm that's the white guy on
the trailer is a villain so the white
guy in the Harriet Tubman's a villain
the white guy in the Charlie I swear to
God
next come our next trailer is for it's a
it's a it's a movie about a black couple
it's the guy from get out right and they
get pulled over by a white cop and
somehow he shoots the cop and then
they're on the run is it what the
trailer is about now guess what the cop
was he was a bad guy he was harassing
them for no reason and they heat and
then the guy and they got in a scuffle
the guy from get out shoots them so now
they're on the run who's that the white
guy is the bad guy uh-huh that's three
trailers in a row I swear to god Eric
okay this is what's happening right now
this is it most people probably don't
even notice these things but I'm
watching it like this is a movie were up
the white guy's not the villain uh I
mean diehard villain like a die-hard -
villain white guy three hear me out
terminate otherwise in full in that our
white guys now we're just a bad guy
the hero was a white guy in the movies
that you just named right now we're not
in it unless we're the bad guy we can
only play the bad guy well I think that
that's like some sort of like you know
what I you know this is what I love cuz
what you're talking about right now is
like when I see a commercial for an
alarm system okay it's a commercial for
an alarm system for your house right and
it's like do you need to get like you
know stay at home safe you know and then
they have a burglar in the house it's
gonna be a white guy yeah yeah but it's
gonna be a white guy because but that's
exactly those of the roles were getting
the bad guy
it's a very interesting time and another
thing I've noticed is that like I look
for I looked at the trailer for Gabriel
Iglesias to show mm-hmm
the one white guy is a chubby redheaded
kid I'm not buying that
I don't even count that as a white guy
that's a redhead there's redheads and
then there's white guys they're separate
sorry Andrew Santino but you know that
even helps him right you know I'm just
spitballing here but a big part of
Andrews charisma and the cool [ __ ] about
I mean like a cool thing that grabs you
right away is I mean it's even in his
show name he's a ginger whiskey ginger
it's not whiskey brunette you know I
mean anyway
and the Wayans show right somehow they
got another show on Netflix and I
watched that trailer
you know that little leave it on trailer
thing oh I haven't seen that not a white
guy so now here's my point is that
things of flipped not only are we the
bad guy and only the bad guy but there's
not even there doesn't have there's no
requirement to have a token white guy on
your show mm-hmm okay here's what I'm
saying to you okay
my pushback on that is this it's like
what you're talking about with the the
referent of the examples you gave it's
like Black History Month okay so you
talking about February right now there's
still 11 other months like you need to
look on Netflix and take a look at of
the 800 things that are on there there
are mostly white every shows white I
don't know what I'm say that white chick
I don't ask the new diversity choice
right but look on Netflix you look on
even network TV man it's still
predominantly white so what what stands
out to you is the shows that you're like
oh here's Charlie's Angels with like one
white girl and they've made this
diversity the other traverse' tea you
know all that it's like which I don't
give a [ __ ] about that I'm you know
right we're not winning because you
decided to make a Charlie's Angels
diverse okay so and then these other
examples it's just those are just the
out layers man the outliers
so I don't think that like although
Hollywood all of a sudden has changed
but they have to they want to show that
to make it seem like there's like oh
look at all the big diversity changes
that they're making but it's really not
right they had I just think that it's
that this is just a few examples that
you gave but it's not the norm the
norther this place is still all white
you believe that yeah because I've been
out I went out for pilot season
right and I'm going out for these shows
and I'm like okay you know I remember
when I went out for this show where I
was be some suntan we gotta eat some
vitamin D in your system how was it this
one showed it was like hey I'm not a
goat farmer from Kentucky you know what
I feel like happens is they write shows
and he is a it might be a white writer
and his white friends and you know let's
just I don't have a problem with that at
all I'm not trying to this ain't no
racial thing for me I'm just saying you
write what you know you know and so if
you're making a show and it just like if
you're making the Tony Hinch hitch clip
Hinchcliffe show we're gonna come and
get it right from now on Tony
Hinchcliffe show and it just so happens
that you know all your friends are white
because maybe you're in Boston and you
whatever you want to show about I don't
have a problem with that but what ends
up happening is when it goes up the
chain now they're looking at it and
they're like ah it's all white all right
let's get this audition some people for
roles that are not written for the
person of color right you know so then
you know you're going that's when I get
called I get cuz I that's what I get you
know they're they're opening the part up
they're looking for that that's what I
always get when I go into auditions
mm-hmm you think they write parts for me
you think there's like you know this is
a multi-ethnic you know that's never
been the case I always have to go for a
part and fight for it or like change
their mind I have to change their mind
to go from like you know and I've just
this has happened to a lot you go out
for these things you see these so I'm
just saying I get your perspective cuz
you your scene is because you're
noticing that but I think you're just
noticing that because you know don't
forget about all the other examples
where it's not that at all cuz we just
kind of we just kind of let that go we
just kind of like flow go with the
program
I guess so I mean I don't know it's it's
an interesting time well I mean I think
that they're like it's just like how
about specials you could probably admit
all right let's even do this you ever
you ever look at the lineups for like
jfl new faces oh not anymore well let me
just tell you it's like it's very
diverse it's you can't you can't even
find yeah but that place is that's what
that pause varieties comics to watch how
about that you ever look at that thank
this guy I'm talking about that was in
Huntsville was on that he was on that
show can't remember which year may have
been last year maybe in the year before
that but one of the years I looked into
it cuz I'm like oh who the [ __ ] are
these people who are these people if I'm
in the game if I'm in the comedy game
and I'm at the Comedy Store four nights
a week and on the road the other three
nights of the week I fill in venues
seeing their lioness seein who they got
coming up in town I'm at the Comedy
Store where there's 40 comedians a night
in LA people from New York's a big top
some of the comments are the biggest
comics in the world rounded economy
stores and I'm looking at these variety
things and sure so well of course they
have to be diverse right I get that I
have no problem with that and I and I
think they do have to certainly meet not
not even a a quota would be an
understated right what your exact so
5050 now they have to be at least 50/50
black and white and male to female right
but and how does that matter if we're
not black and white it's 50 percent
black 20 percent Latino and Latina you
have to have one or two or one or two
anyway it was either last year the year
before I looked into who the two white
guys were that made it in and they were
both gay out booing Lee get they talk
about being gay right so you basically
see there was no straight white male
she turned it on no boat straight white
males earner nothing on my shoulder
[ __ ] bad guy haha hi okay I
worked all this time yes a good straight
white male and now the mainstream it's
like and by the way they're still there
likes isn't breaking anybody anymore
that's not a thing anymore you know I my
special that I made in 2015 got a
license for two years right that was the
deal so I still own it
unlike most Netflix specials where they
own it forever and you never get to do
anything with it or have it or sell it
or anything and it was a great thing but
then when the two years was up that two
years was up and now it's like now they
don't break anybody there's nothing
happening over there
wins so now well nobody nobody is
retiring there's 500 specials it seems
like there's on there so they're doing
something yeah they're doing something
but none of them are straight white
males Nate bargatze is the only one in I
mean probably he's got a show he's got a
show coming out oh yeah he's the hero on
what it's like ABC or CBS oh yeah it's
fun is you know what's funny is this an
IRA irony of this is I was going out I
was gonna audition to be his friend on
the show and then like I know one of the
creators who said I think his friend
probably should be white so I'm just
saying that's an example was out there
happening I guess so you're gonna end up
watching it it'll be Jerrod Carmichael
you're gonna be like damn it because
he's behind the camera making it that's
so funny
himself
there's the irony in that right no but I
get what you're saying I do feel like
there's like a push back I feel like
that too straight white males out there
who are not racist
we're not me to in chicks right they're
just out here living trying to survive
like everybody else they're getting
lumped in with like all of the bad
people there you go you know and I get
that that's all I'm saying I get what
you're saying
and
I feel that way but see you extrapolated
further I feel that way about like with
the me too I feel that way about like
where it's like we're all bad if you're
a man you're bad right now but there's
levels to it so I get what you're saying
you're trying to say like hey that's
that's kind of kind of straight white
guy have a show anymore right without
people being like oh here we go again
well there's people out there who would
be like hey you had you're talking right
you had ten thousand years that's what
that's what they say and that's the most
perhaps racist thing to say its finest
yes like oh well you already had your
run it's our turn now well it's like
alright let's see how that goes
keep saying that we always going to need
straight white males of the power race
right now do we need we need straight
black females more in this when we come
back unwritten Griffin it's like you can
only even say that about straight white
males right now we'll really need
straight white men we really need they
do we really need gay Latinas and on
this planet has a different ring right
you know it's funny what you're talking
about right now is I feel this way about
like how the difference between men and
women like like what women can get away
with what they say about men like
especially female comics like the things
that they could say about men on stage I
mean it's crazy so it's the same kind of
thing here is what you're saying is like
you know it's easy to bash straight
white males right you know so I just
know there's no advocate for straight
white males there's nobody's feeling
sorry for you [ __ ] it's just
boom you know they but so you're you're
feeling a little sensitive you and your
feelings about it I mean ya know it's
one of those things to where I mean I'm
just for example you know
I like I like having a big successful
podcast whatever we're doing great on
the road we take it out and everybody
has fun you know it's all about comedy
this and that and it's great and it's
doing great
but it's like you know I've I'd love for
other things to sort of fall into place
like what you know let me give you an
example like when I started writing on
The Comedy Central Roast you know eight
nine years ago or whatever they were
breaking people through right Whitney
Cummings
we sent Anthony Jeselnik both came
Schumer on the Trump roast that was
their debut really to America right
nobody really had any idea who they were
when that came out Amy Schumer the next
year was on these people all came
originally from the writing room onto
the roast now you know I got in the
writers room I knew I was already you
know on a path to becoming a decent
stand-up comedian I was doing the right
work doing a lot of spots they're like
you know I'm thinking about what would I
have to do oh maybe I should you know
write well first of all to really make
an impact with the execs and the EPS
they'll see how you know what I mean
when when that's like a percentage of
the jokes that make it into the show or
from me that they're gonna know like
that would be what Jeselnik and Whitney
and in Schumer did write that's what
that's what just says not to cut you off
but what I was going to say is like so
in your mind you're thinking because
it's old-school mentality if I put in
the work and I do my time I'm gonna get
my chance yep
and I did everything else you know what
I mean I made my own special I got my
social media following up I have a loyal
base out there yeah listens to me for an
hour and a half every single week hosts
this chaotic show right you can't beat
that connection I mean unless you're Joe
Rogan who's doing you know four three
hour episodes a week you know really
just talking so then he comes to your
town you have to go to an arena and see
him right like that it's just the more
you know people listen to us sometimes
more than they talk to their mother or
father in a week think about that an
hour a week
I have a friend of mine that says to me
all the time like I'll talk about things
on this you know hit me up and be like
bro I didn't even know that about you
right you know I didn't know you know
it's like I'm revealing information
about myself like in this environment
more than I would and like in a regular
conversation so it's like it's really
weird but I get what you saying so
you're on the roasts and you know you're
writing and and now it's what now it's
like my hip
this one this one coming up is like
would be my seventh roast that I'm
writing on oh wow and here we go we have
everything there and you know Comedy
Central's not some [ __ ] sorry but
it's not you know dominating it's not it
doesn't have the monopoly on comedy like
it once had yeah so now it's like you
know and so who gets that spot right
we know Jeff Ross is gonna be on at the
roastmaster general executive producer
right sure of course he's the roast
master so she's gonna be on it and and
so now it's just yet right
so they gave it to Pete Davidson two
years ago because he's on SNL why is he
on SNL why is he on SNL he's 20 at the
time he was 21 or 22 why not because
he's funny no cuz his dad died in 9/11
so they can rationalize him being the
young straight white male on SNL I can't
talk bad about him his dad died in 9/11
he's talking that's the whole story
that's his entire story that's the whole
thing you're wondering like Oh what's
your favorite Pete Davidson thing in SNL
history I don't watch a so now you're
right dammit that's exactly my point I
stopped watching it so years ago you
know who like what you know it's like
who dated ariana grande but that was
before this was before he got Ariana
Grande cuz he was booked on a [ __ ]
roast I could have been me
that was the Bieber roast yeah I wanted
to be on the Bieber right now so did I
I'm a real fan of Bieber
I mean I got to acoustic album you know
I mean absolutely
he's got your album too he himself was
asking me about being on the roasts he
said yeah you should be on my roast yeah
but I got you're talking a scooter and
it was just like I knew it wasn't gonna
happen nobody knows me would have been
Hosting would have been about like why
is this nobody here and all thing is
that's great yes you want to be you want
to be the nobody yeah right instead of
it being lame you know jokes about SNL
it could be lame jokes about your
podcast
that'd be great I mean what the time I
didn't have the podcast right but you
know what I mean I'll get you in so like
so then what happened you feel passed
over of course yeah now if there's a
straight white male on it it's a legend
it's a freak it's not some it's you know
not some regular dude right okay well my
pushback on that is like I always say
this I would love to be mediocre on
Netflix because it seems to be that like
that's all it takes for a lot of like
straight white males I'm not gonna go
call and pee come on you know me but
it's just like there's a lot but first
of all you you you think is like every
special that comes out on Netflix is
great no no but there's guys that they
but they give these people opportunities
I guess you like it to be to be a person
of color on Netflix you gotta be
ginormous you have to be the biggest guy
in comedy you gotta be Chappelle Chris
Rock you gotta be these guys or they're
not just like you then I can give him
like Tony Baker a shot you know why not
he's just as funny as a lot of the white
guys that are on that are on and even
white girls that are on Netflix I mean I
agree with that you know so I just like
I mean so that's my pushback on that is
like yeah so if you're saying that
straight white males now have to work
harder and be more dynamic at what they
do to get to get over welcome to the
party I mean that's always though that's
always how it is you know I think we're
seeing two different sides of this no no
of course yes I'm seeing your III who
they pick as their straight white males
is I mean other than a few exceptions
like you know Chris D'Elia is amazing
he's a monster Canadian Tom Segura
unbelievable amazing Rogan right these
people are freaks
but in that broken doesn't wanna do that
kind of [ __ ] what you think it would be
on a roast
no I'm talking about I'm talking about
Netflix special okay guys you got you're
talking about like who they really have
in their wrote
basically once a year right bill burr
monster sure established right and I'm
not saying I'm saying the ones I'm
saying the ones right now yeah and
looked at the specials there'd be a lot
of who's that really yeah who's this
dude really how'd this guy you think we
don't know them yeah I think so yeah
I've already done this I've already been
like cuz I cuz I'm bitter like that over
the year I didn't get a half-hour from
Comedy Central yeah being on at the time
their hit show right and I was passed
over - III couldn't get a half hour I
watched every [ __ ] episode that year
Wow I'm at home by myself like who [ __ ]
that who's that
oh this - dude why is he on there you
know and then you know when I finally
got it I was like at that plant couldn't
even enjoy it cuz I was so like that
chip on my shoulder was like keeping my
happiness down - so I'm sure I've gotten
past all that kind of stuff
you know I mean but it's like it like I
say it is what it is right
that's its it's their choice yeah like
it doesn't make any sense it's like
Netflix isn't government-owned ok it's
not a government property it's a private
business and they can decide who the
[ __ ] they want on their thing they have
their algorithm and if their algorithm
says we want this kind of P if they if
they have an algorithm on that Netflix
and it says the more white people we
have on our network the more people
subscribe then that's what they're gonna
do you know so I you know it's a private
business you know saying well no that
they would Monique you know she was mad
that they didn't you know give her any
Schumer money I was like are you out of
your [ __ ] mind
yeah that was psychotic are you out of
your mind you should like all these
comics getting specials they should
actually pay Netflix I agree I actually
you should pay them because they're
putting you in front of a hundred and
thirty million people you know I mean I
just did that Sandler movie yeah you
know and it's like amazing the reach so
many people hit me like I was like wow
imagine if you had a special that they
promoted if they if you if you have a
special and they decide I'm gonna put
you're special it could be life-changing
oh yeah if it's good oh yeah so it's
like take that shot or if they make it
good you know another thing that they do
now is a lot of editing tricks I've
noticed you leave that space for after
and they [ __ ] I just watch it right
in there it's a television show yeah
it's supposed to be for entertainment
right I have no problem with that kind
of stuff yeah punching up the other yeah
I have no patience what if the material
is absolute garbage though check it out
yeah it's a television show all right
it's that's the CGI that's needed for
people at home who are paying at $15 a
month they want to enjoy this you're
speaking as a comic as a student of the
game as a person that is like caring for
the artform
you need to tell people go watch it live
because that's what I say go watch it
live because that [ __ ] you see in the
specials and stuff that's not how it
really is right that's not how it really
is and you'll enjoy yourself a thousand
times more like you know go see Chris
D'Elia live you know you're gonna
experience something and you might see
something that you'll never see again
yeah that [ __ ] they're supposed to live
on the TV forever it has to be pristine
yeah it has to be a certain way you know
and just I don't have a problem with
that yeah no I get that but I but I also
get the other side that people like
Europe you're a purist it also just I
guess one of the things that concerns me
about that is I want the people on the
line to become a stand-up fan I want
people to want to see a live show and I
feel like if they're watching a special
and they hear that astounding laughter
and they don't think it's funny that
they'll be like you know I just don't
really think stand-up comedy's for me
like I'm not laughing as hard as those
be like here's the thing though but see
what you're talking about is like it's
like putting rims on a BMW okay it's the
the the factory models still pretty good
right okay so you I just put some rims
in a tent that doesn't mean that like
that changed it so much know what you're
talking about is when a Toyota comes off
the lot
and they try to put a BMW kit on it okay
that's when you're like
right this isn't working that's what I'm
talking okay well I'm not talking I'm
talking about the bad ones yeah I'm
talking about the people that they're
trying to shoehorn in or give a second
or third special to a little bit too
quick sometimes yeah well but see but
here's the thing too this is a change in
times specials now are just content that
like that's comedians YouTube videos
that's they're like this is our content
we got to put it out put another one out
put another one out it's just it we have
to change the the paradigm the the how
we think about what specials are
supposed to be there's just comedy
videos it's just
here's people's material that they've
worked on this year and they put that
out for you and I'm gonna work on
something else it's not necessarily the
work the word special is what confuses
people now we need to almost take that
out of it mm-hmm you know we need to
find a new name for it yeah stop calling
is special you're right they blew that
when they made the 15-minute specials
and they told everybody to promote it
and call it a special yeah yeah this is
like now you got people you know you
bring in somebody up to 15 minutes yeah
I keep waiting for the like you know 100
5 minute specials coming out tomorrow
and midnight you know yeah you're gonna
be like [ __ ] but they need to change
remember what caused you and your head
to $6 burger mm-hmm it was called the $6
burger but it was only like $4 mm-hmm
but when you hear that in your head you
go something you're thinking well I'm
getting a deal because I'm getting a $6
burger for only $4 right no it's just a
name yeah it's not worth $6 so that's
what I feel about comedy specials
they're not special
yeah just a name like Charmin or you
know bounty now yeah you know the
Kleenex yeah it's just that it's just a
title for it that we've now and it's in
our head there we go you're special you
know now we I like when people say oh
I'm doing my hour yeah I'm doing my hour
on whatever that's somebody that
understands right you're [ __ ] ain't
special right running an hour
yeah I'm just running my hour on Netflix
for people to see yeah you know like how
it's so hard to capture live stand-up
comedy that magic that happens
you know you're at the Comedy Store and
you could like you know it's like a 10
o'clock 10:30 you know you go up and
like you have to go up after like
whoever you know the crowd is on fire or
something's happening in the crowd and
you know you go up and you have one of
these like magical moments that [ __ ]
can't be captured right you know and
occasionally it is occasionally somebody
puts together something that is like
it's explosive for them like Ali Wong
her first special there was something
about it that people it resonated with
people and it made her a star it happens
to some people you know what I mean
but like I can think of like five of
those in my entire life that you know
Chris Rock has one of them but there's
some of his other specials I was like
it's great great you know you know good
good hour but it wasn't like wow I just
saw something special right that rarely
happens yeah and even with the Great's
of these 20 million-dollar specials that
we just saw on Netflix what about Eddie
Murphy what do you think I mean like did
I think that Eddie Murphy not doing
stand-up for a long time this is what I
think in my head I just feel like he has
such a profound respect for stand-up
comedy I just think that he has this
thing where he's like you know he's like
I am I don't want to do that I don't
want to go cause he was like so great
and even if he wasn't great
we made him great yeah you know what I
mean yeah cuz when you look at delirious
now it doesn't stand up it's not I just
go oh my god this is because so many
people look like these jokes for 30
years that when you look at the original
you're like ah well you know but what
I'm saying is like he still revered as
one of the great stand-ups of all time
performers and so to live up to that
okay I don't want any what is he who
could he possibly do but here's the
thing though like I am interested to see
if he's serious about it don't you want
to see him in the Ori like a lesson
learned weren't working out like about
his made whatever the [ __ ] he's gonna
talk about going to coffee bean or like
dating a being rich or like whatever I
just can't picture it I know but that's
okay you know what and I think he knows
that right I think that he's like damn
what I think he thinks the same [ __ ]
what am I gonna talk about right I'm not
even in touch with the world anymore I
never leave my house I go to coffee bean
and I go home right I wear sunglasses
and a jolene yeah really oh there was
that one coffee bean he's always at one
in the valley really yeah always makes
jokes about it hey which coffee bean you
want to me that you know the one on
whatever or Eddie Murphy yeah yeah the
famous coffee bean he always went to so
I'm just saying he's not in regular
society anymore he was just one of these
he's such an icon of comedy right you
know he's upped it to me it's like Bob
Hope Eddie Murphy that's how you would
talk about it right and now he wants to
come back and do this thing that he's I
mean aren't you I'm fascinated even if
he bombs terribly I want to see what
that is looks like it's definitely going
I would yes I definitely want to see
what it looks like you know what I think
he should do huh this is my honest
opinion if I ever met him I would tell
him this hmm she should get roasted it
would be it would change everything
mm-hmm like he should allow himself to
in the end then let him say anything
yeah like the transgender do all that
[ __ ] let him go buck while on him and
then have his opportunity to go up and
roll because the people that would be on
the panel it's gonna be our CEO
Chappelle Chris Rock you know all the
dudes from SNL Dana Carvey and all these
guys are gonna be the ones that are
gonna do it right hey and then have him
have his time that's how I would want to
come back you know that'd be great for
him it would be good it would be
tremendous for him roasts are great for
people yeah many people get to see
people laughing at themselves and it's a
big deal especially all the rumors and
things they've heard about if he just
allows it just like go ahead say
whatever you want yeah you know and it
really helps people be accepted by the
mains
don't forget you know Donald Trump years
ago it was the roast of Donald Trump
yeah at the end of it people don't even
remember this
at the end of it red white and blue
confetti comes from the ceiling the
American flag as the backdrop pops up a
flag waving in the background all these
seeds were planted a long time ago
damn yep the chair that he sits in on
the apprentice is basically the you know
like the main white house had a table
chair I know
all office in the press conference table
exactly the you know I've talked about
this before but I remember I saw Chris
Rock right before he was doing the the
Oscars you know and he was preparing he
was going to the clubs mhm
he was on stage and I'd never forget
this he goes he's like Donald Trump's
coming and everybody's I you know had
been there things like hey he's like
Donald Trump do you realize how famous
Donald Trump is this how he was talking
about it Donald Trump is still famous
like Ronald Reagan won cuz he was famous
he was like he was trying to compare do
you know how much more famous Donald
Trump is then Ronald Reagan he was like
Ronald Reagan was like Eric Roberts you
think about say dude is he is like we
really love Fame yeah love like what we
think we know about people
yeah right I tried to get Joe Rogan
there were some questions now in 2020
but I tried to get him in 2016 I think
he would have been able to beat Trump I
believe that I'm calling my
ex-girlfriend by accident I know and I
don't know how to crazy I can't talk
right now
I did this by accident sorry okay I'm
doing my podcast that is you're actually
all my pockets I gotta go
hilarious all right and hahaha you gotta
keep that in maybe I like it okay um
you roll getting broken can be President
could have been he could have won this
2016 election if you think we're Oggy
gonna one he's disease that I don't
think he's that famous I think that like
hi
I think it is funny about podcasting is
it's more of a specialized audience it's
not true fame okay because it's even if
they'll audiences is large and he has
the largest there's still a baby and a
dog on the internet that Dwarfs anything
Rogaine can do you know I mean I mean
there's there's dudes out there that are
playing basketball in Venice Beach okay
they're just uh they're just out they
did they just go a white guy in jeans
and he plays with this guy that guy's
got a million followers and it's growing
every day he's playing basketball a
short in the dog videos short I'm just
saying there's a lot of people out there
that like have like equivalent type of
following and fame on YouTube but it
doesn't translate to the American people
man
it doesn't you know the people that did
more people watch NCIS they're still
watching that show okay
I show they gets like 10 million viewers
a week you know there's still more
popular more famous things than podcast
- sure of course we letting this get to
our heads but it's not that important I
guess so
you know what I mean all right I mean
okay you don't agree comparing Rogen the
basketball videos I know no I'm talking
about I'm talking about the reach of
YouTube I'm not talking about I'm not
talking about it's not a comparison I'm
just saying you know I'm just saying I'm
just saying I did it's just that's just
did you know I think that him I think
that if he was in there he would stir
things up and he would be more of a
truth bomb layer like I think one of the
things that I think one of the things
that Trump does is he says something and
then the media cuts out part of what he
says and then they say the one thing
that he said you know what I mean like
grab women by the [ __ ] for example
mm-hmm like it's like he didn't say he
grabs women by the [ __ ] he was saying
that we the whole quote like oh there's
a whole beginning of that paragraph that
they cut out you know he's talking to
some other famous dude about being
famous and yeah I mean your fan you know
these chicks over here crazy you know
when you're famous they'll let you do
anything you know what I mean
I don't let you grab them by the [ __ ]
he's not saying he does it it's like
Andy's right I always thought of it like
a euphemism like if I said you know man
I hit it last night yeah they took that
they'd be like and it's like even like
even a few days ago he's like you know
Baltimore is a rat-infested city and we
were like oh my god how could he say
that about a city in America have you
been to Baltimore lately it's [ __ ]
disgusting and it's like when the media
blows this stuff up people with that
know that have common sense you know
what I mean
they're they're taking these people the
other direction
Wabble like me that's a more here that
and go yeah Baltimore is a [ __ ] and
him saying that might actually help them
get funding or get their [ __ ] together
do something might know how it's been
going
isn't I get what you're saying and I
don't I don't necessarily disagree but
my problem that with any president that
can't that I don't have a problem with a
strong president it has a strong hand I
don't mind a president just like yo NATO
pay your bills right
yo China yeah you not get placing
tariffs yeah I don't mind like somebody
that has that but at the same time lead
all of us you know if you polarize
people right then I'm not with you yeah
so all the goods that he might be doing
with the economy and whatever choices
he's made to make America seem strong at
the same time he's alienating is some of
his own people and putting us against
each other and that part of it I just
don't like yeah you know I don't I
didn't like it in any and any president
okay who this Clinton Obama Bush's again
I think the media pushes a lot of that
storyline forward though a lot of it no
and he does nothing and he could to
correct it and he could I think no I
don't think so I think he I think that I
think this is a separ achey out of
prison and sweet I think it's all
calculated you know like I remember
seeing a
uhh Trevor Noah show one and he was
showing Trump and he was some Trump's at
this rally yeah and this is always
talking he goes you know they told me to
say drain the swamp I didn't like it at
first
this is Trump talking yeah cuz I don't
like it but they said it would work and
he was like ok you know and the crowd
you can hear the crowd kind of going
what wait what it's almost like he was
letting them know oh I got over on you
too right like you're like he I just
feel he's still arrogant that he's like
yeah I want you to know that I fooled
you right I beat he's he's actually a
fantastic politician yeah you know but
like I could campaign to be the lion
tamer at the circus mm-hmm you know I
bet you I can win I could be like yo
it's Montana workaholism
riffing with Griffin I could be on their
lines you know I could probably win but
then you know what I have to do after
that when I win you got a team the line
i gotta tame the lion so [ __ ] and that's
what i'm like I don't really am not
qualified for this that's what this
[ __ ] just did you know he's he's
not a I don't think he's a bad dude but
he's just not qualified to be president
it's a bigger job that he's able to do
and look at look so many people quit his
cabinet all the stuff that's going on he
could like that should happen again
that's another thing again the media
makes it look like these people are
quitting and everything is a trump if
you look at every other presidency all
the same stuff happens a new pit bulls
pit bulls strike they better like Tony
it's not all propaganda but a lot of it
is I mean I'm telling you in the way
that they push these things helps him it
does not hurt him when they when they
say that he said that all Mexicans are
rapists not at all what he said I mean
it's crazy if you go back and listen to
the actual sound clip that what I'm
saying is he literally says some of
these people he doesn't make any effort
to he doesn't mind being known that way
and I don't like that and you know but
here's the thing though and I mean and
I'm not just like some like trump
defender you know what I mean I just
I'm sort of in awe of his style and how
it works I will say that is like 100 we
are 100 agreement about that I just go
wow this guy is complaining on one thing
he doesn't do and I think this goes
along with the correct yourself thing is
he does not apologize he's causing for
anything he's record comic every week
there's another hysteria going on this
is the thing I see Judd Apatow on
Twitter like this is it impeachment
right he's losing his [ __ ] mind
yeah and then nothing happens gone it
fades away I think that the day that
Trump apologizes for anything is the
days I'm telling you breathe but there's
probably a couple of Tony type guys no
yeah that's involved in his habit Jared
Kushner he's like yo bro because me
because I think the trumps like should
we do something about that they kind of
they're saying this stuff about me and
these guys are going nah man this is
perfect let it ride let it ride this out
you know you're gonna get more followers
this way and I think that that but my
problem is is I think that's what's
wrong with it you know like I think that
there's something unamerican about you
know trying to try to like circumvent
the system to try to like you know Wayne
you know to your advantage let me also
say this it's like I'm I'm gonna get to
my questions mess I'll get to him
interesting thing is is like everybody
says you know like he's a racist and
this and that and it's like people need
nice that time and time again right
right and racists are racist and this is
a thing that like you know what I hate
about this is people again it like makes
us [ __ ] look bad right just straight
white males yeah because it's like this
this thing where remember how crazy it
was when they were when you know the
police you know accidentally killed a
couple black guys and like all of a
sudden everyone's looking at police like
they're the scum of the earth and this
and that and it's crazy
all across America because it wasn't
helpful but I got you right was a few
but it was more than a couple was more
than two right you know we shouldn't we
shouldn't act like it was
I should have said a few but the couple
were the famous ones right there was two
like really famous ones one where he got
choked and the one where he got shot but
then there was another whether the kid
with a cop they had the video of the kid
you know the cops jump out of the car
with their guns and they fire on this
little kid who had a fake gun in his
hand yeah yeah I mean there's a lot of
them there's a lot but I get what you're
saying we're go on right the media
doesn't help in these situations in hell
you don't help they may they inspire
hysteria without any context right
there's no there's no there's no the
hysteria and it's maybe you want and
they don't necessarily cover the things
that he says that does he's an again
he's not apologizing they'll say there's
I don't have a racist bone in my body
you know they don't take that soundbite
and feed it to you Trump says he doesn't
have a racist bone in his body one
network does well yeah one network does
you know but so people are living in two
different universes and I think that's
are like I agree with Bill Maher I think
all the Democratic presidential
candidates need to go on Fox News
I'm telling go on Fox News talk to the
other side I saw it happen I saw a
Kamala come out Camilla Harris Camilla
is that it Camilla just like how just
how bad people can't say hitch class
Camilla Camilla Harris was on Fox and a
few days ago and she was killing it yeah
look at her the other side needs to see
that's all that it is absolutely you
know but again like I don't think I
don't I don't take you as a pro Trump
guy I just think you're just taking a
over view assessment I'm a governmental
optimist what we call it is it's like
America will never do anything in its
it's impossible for us to not be the
world superpower well he's making it the
the the feeling around him is putting a
little tarnish on a little blemish on
the idea of what democracy is supposed
to be this is what I don't like is like
that he inspires like races have been
hidden away for a while
you know some of some of the true ones
and lri no no but now there's someone
out of there below there
not yes this is the problem this is I
see I got off track a few minutes I met
you back on go yet I'm glad that you
know is that they're not they're not
they're not they're not that's
Charlottesville thing that got blown up
those are people that traveled from all
around the country people think there's
like this hub of Rio these are just the
racists in Charlottesville look at that
no that was a gigantic meeting and they
tried that [ __ ] again they had a big one
like a couple months ago there was seven
people that seven people and they cover
it the way they shoot these things and
everything is like you know shaky-cam
and you can't see anything and like
there's seven people and that's a
nationwide meeting man and let me tell
you something from what I understand
from back in the day when racism was
real they weren't proud people racist
you don't get you didn't get straight
white males no race racists
they were mostly straight white sure of
course yeah of course again way to help
this were straight you know it looks
like the soundbite that ends my career
males are racist you ever hear a table
full of black women talk about women
Chinese girls all right come on anyway
why'd you continue that racists are it's
not a [ __ ] thing and it's like it's
so rare like in the middle of the
country what are you really talking
about there's probably three goddamn
racist white people in all the [ __ ]
Los Angeles right now they're people
that goof around and make jokes
almost every we will still have
prejudice man I think there's still
prejudice people out there I think
people are tribal I think people are you
know they like to be around people that
they you know look like and I think
they're in the same circle and I also
think that
the same you know this doesn't mean it's
a racism I'm just saying that I think
that you know that I think that
tribalism she's disguised is mistaken
for you also think that there's
something in the air where people want
to be accepted by the other people of
course I think that you see a [ __ ]
you know uh you know a cool black guy
somewhere I always give the head nod you
know what I mean well I mean who you
think's buying rap albums it's great
it's like me I'm bi
so like I got into this argument the
other day out on the street actually it
was like a few months ago
actually it was probably like a year ago
I got in this big argument with this guy
angry old white guy I pulled up my car
real quick in front of my building to uh
to grab something out of my apartment
real quick and I parked real close
behind this Prius parked there and I
mean real close like right on the trunk
I run in I come out thirty seconds right
and there's some old guy with shopping
bags standing I like the [ __ ] is this I
don't know and I'm later like what's up
man how you doing today cuz you know cuz
I can tell like he's sort of angry he
goes man I'd be better if you didn't
pull right up on my ass like that I got
yeah but it's all good I just had to
grab something out of my apartment real
quick I'm leaving right now
I have a great day man you know still
pushing the bride right right right
and he's like I mean again I would be
having a good day but I mean who parks
like who do you think you are who do I
think I am I'm just some guy to get
something I'm one more time giving him
one more yeah strike three and he's like
you know yeah I mean it's just
unbelievable how your Park ago you know
how the [ __ ] are you complaining about
the [ __ ] are you complain that's my part
I had to grab something now I'm [ __ ]
leaving so goodbye
he's like you know yeah get in the car
that Daddy bought you and get out of
here no I got this from chasing my
dreams and accomplishing things so that
I don't end up a bitter old man driving
a [ __ ] Prius when I'm older carrying
my own goddamn grocery bags being
in the middle of a beautiful day right
and now we're going back and forth now
I'm getting back now you can't tell
who's who
right right and like you know my point
is is like you know it's just like
[ __ ] are [ __ ] bad people are bad
people what color whereas freely and it
really you know silly and simple as that
sounds I think that deep down I think
everybody knows that unless they believe
that the news is really the news I gotta
even stop calling it the news like it's
like specials yeah you know I mean we
got stopped using the word special we
got usually we're new another thing is
like you know I think one of the things
were Trump sort of went wrong was by him
calling at the fake news all the time he
did that and you know what it is fake
and because he called it that it gets
this bad like he calls it fake news cuz
it affects him negatively you know you
know what I mean it almost would have
been better to just ride it out without
him quit that because then maybe
something could be done about it you
know honestly I almost think it's all in
cahoots with one another I think that
the people that seem like they're
against him are really with them and the
people that seem like they're with them
over at Fox are probably actually
against him just waiting it out well I
think that there are people at Fox News
like the actual people that do the news
not the people that look like they're
doing the news cuz they're also sitting
at a desk and there's [ __ ] behind them
it looks the same as the news but
they're these are just people like
they're doing a podcast basically
they're doing a video pie like Sean
Hannity is like that's a podcast oh yeah
you know and he's just talking you know
straight to propaganda one just straight
to camera
[Laughter]
[ __ ] here we go we got the Rat King
here comes ten angry tweets you're just
mad cause you don't have the success all
right but I just think that that's I
agree with you though because there are
people if you watch Fox News you know
they're some of them are really harsh
with their hard on him they're like yeah
they want to you know they want the
balanced measured approach but that's
all you're trying to say right and
that's the final thing that I'll say is
I think Fox News has etched more towards
the middle and the other networks
I mean Evans NBC is psychotic
crying almost once a week I mean [ __ ]
some believe that are psychotic I was
all and I was off that when like when
you know here's Trump's taxes so you're
gonna show us that he paid there's so
mad everybody all these people always
bankrupt oh he's never been able to run
a business it's like at least give the
guy cause this again this is what they
like to do it's like oh he doesn't even
know how to run a business that thing
went bankrupt I'm like do you know what
bankruptcy means I know these people and
it's like guys worth four billion
dollars like it's like sorry sorry you
got to start being honest if you want to
beat them yeah they're trying to beat
them with this [ __ ] chaos like oh
he's a racist he's a blah blah blah
meanwhile it's like nope Baltimore's a
[ __ ] some of the Mexican some of the
Mexican people that illegally come here
do rape people it does happen they do
sometimes murder people right he is
using that as a thing and it's like you
know what I mean like people take that
and they make it like he thinks and by
the way the women that he was talking
about it whatever party when you are
famous guess what they do probably let
you grab them by the [ __ ] and by the
way that's a [ __ ] recorded
conversation with him and some other
dude off the record behind the thing
that comes out like it's like and
meanwhile they pretend like oh this
never would have happened you know what
I mean it just would have been a better
world like hillary was supposed to win
really Hillary I just I just watched a
Andy's five-part series the
an affair that really [ __ ] I mean I
I'm telling you Eric I very rarely
recommend things cuz it's so there's so
much entertainment nowadays this or not
you gotta go to A&E go to your Amazon or
whatever and buy it as you go or
whatever the Clinton affair and the
interviews that they have with everybody
in Clinton's office everybody except for
[ __ ] Al Gore and Bill Clinton and
Hillary themselves and they go through
the entire Clinton years and it's just
so funny to see the hypocrisy I mean
this dude is getting his [ __ ] dick
swallowed in the Oval Office the
hypocrisy of both sides like Hillary's
some angel like that's the most house of
cards [ __ ] family I mean it's good
[ __ ] definitely based off of [ __ ] the
Clintons there's no doubt about that
[ __ ] well anyway I don't know man I
can't believe how political we got today
I probably just lost half my fan base
you know listen we just wanna this is
what needs to happen in the world people
need to discuss things in a measured
approach just like think about what
we're talking about you know we can't
take everything that we hear at face
value because what do we really know we
don't know anything right and then our
source of information we can't trust it
it's like how are we supposed to know
and all I'm saying is I wish that he
would be it stop being such a politician
about everything like not everything has
to be about you know getting the upper
hand right and that's what it feels like
it feels like just people behind him
going like like the guy that's going hey
let's just ride this out because I don't
like that I want him to be like no I
don't want to ride this out because I
don't want people feeling this way right
I think I feel like he should the
president I mean just him I'm just
thinking the Office of the President
should take care of the people and and
how they feel about the presidency the
country and each other if we were at war
with anyone if there was any drone
strikes anything happening I think it
would be a completely different
situation but you also have to factor in
and
nobody mentions this this is one of the
most anti-war prayer it's were four
years in now dude this is yeah this is
the most anti-war president you don't
Rob Lee ever had in our lifetime you
know what's crazy what if he brokers
peace in the Middle East and all those
people sit down at a table like what are
they gonna say I'll tell you what it is
because it's the exact same thing that
just happened with North Korea I'll tell
you exactly what they would say they
would say there's no reason why an
American president should even be
talking with or negotiating with these
people it's the exact same thing yeah if
he shakes hands with Putin they go look
look he's conniving with Putin
it shakes hands with the most evil world
leaders these are guys that would be on
the cover of Mad Magazine right kim
jeong-hoon oh oh he shouldn't be really
he shouldn't be or is that one of the
most groundbreaking things getting these
people on his side whether he uses them
or abuses them with what cards them
famous thing from The Godfather you know
keep your enemies close keep your
friends close and your enemies closer
damn [ __ ] right and you gotta
give that guy some credit for than that
I mean that's the whole thing is like
everybody just wants to bash it but I'm
saying if you want to beat him you have
to start people have to start being
honest like I was watch maybe
let's end this [ __ ] these Democratic
debates you love this because this is
now you don't have to be a host you just
sitting here and you're you're getting
all this stuff out I mean you know what
this is gonna be part one tony
Hinchcliffe part one okay I'm gonna get
to the questions you know I mean you got
thanks for all your questions and you
know but Tom we've been talking and
talking and talking I got to get this
guy out of here I'll have all Tony's
information a lot of you probably
already know because
the podcast world is small I appreciate
you coming on Thank You Man you're one
of my favorite people you're one of my
favorite guests on kill Tony you are
truly absolutely hilarious I look up to
you
you're a [ __ ] great actor you're a
good-looking guy
you're just a good human you're a real
comedian I appreciate you man and I do
want to make it a regular thing oh yeah
we did get like a lot of deep here and I
hope people when you when you when you
listen to this it's like what you know
what do you talk about some serious
subjects maybe or save your tweets in
your hate instagrams I already know save
your [ __ ] thumb energy all right I
know you hate me I know you hate my
voice go [ __ ] do something productive
with your bag I don't need to hear it I
already know I don't give a [ __ ] yeah
there we go
I love only yeah it's not easy no
there's a reason why no one else is
talking about the good sides of Trump
and the lack of straight white males in
the media it's because they don't want
to talk about it you got to give me
credit for at least having the balls
ease you you are shaking that subject
hand like Kim Jong feel comfortable
talking about it with you the testament
to you you know I don't agree with
everything that you rent you're saying
okay but it's like but you should be
allowed to say it we should be able to
have an honest dialogue that's what's
needed is have a dialogue yeah go into
the nuance have a measured approach and
if we don't agree in the end at least we
know where each other stands yeah you
know and I agree with you if you guys
out there if you wanna beat Trump if
that's your thing if that's your goal
you better get out there and understand
that [ __ ] right know you're in
I'm a pony yes
know your enemy it's crazy I know well
we're gonna end on that um thanks once
again for the very funny and insightful
Tony Hinchcliffe for coming on the
podcast thanks for listening River with
Griffin and I'll see you guys next week
bye
[Applause]